um let's see we should have 10 and we
have 2 4 6 8 we are missing Joe and we
are missing who else
missing at Caitlin but she's not here
so she she is she's Disneyland she might
well I do think of Shakespeare exactly
do you know that today is the perfect
date
I call to order this
special committee on the Family Division
and I've got an opening statement which
I hope will set the tone I've had much
of this with different individuals but
now this is for the record
the immediate cause of this special
committee is the experience at the
beginning of the 2023
2024 term of the house children and
family law committee
several bills with which we were
presented addressed perceived errors on
the part of the family division of
circuit court in the state of New
Hampshire
subsequent testimony by Bill sponsors
and by the general public alleged among
other things fail you failure to follow
or enforce statutes
unwarranted waiver of or failure to
follow court rules
delay in rendering decisions denial of
due process and other procedural issues
this is consistent with comments I've
testimony from representatives of the
judicial branch
deny these things were taking place
so whom do we believe
how can we put a lot of these
allegations to rest what do we do going
forward
as chairman of that children and family
law committee I arranged for a meeting
with the honorable Gordon McDonald Chief
Justice of the Supreme Court The
Honorable David King administrative
judge of the circuit court and others
we arranged for the first of what we
hope will be a series of continuing
education days for both the house
children and family law committee and
the house Judiciary Committee
however we came to believe more was
needed
hence the constituting of this special
committee it consists of 10 members
chosen equally among the two political
parties represented in the house and
equally among the children and family
law Committee in the Judiciary Committee
it was my privilege to do the voir deer
those considered for membership were
individuals who were deemed to be
impartial
that is they were known they were not
known to be of strong opinions about
Family Court one way or the other
they had not recently
served as lawyers representing anyone in
cases before Family Court
they had not recently been a judge
we wanted people who could be neutral in
hearing what was presented to us
testimony will be collated by the two
committee secretaries appointed one of
whom is away this week
and the Coalition will be primarily on
the basis of topics that's a little
different from the minutes of most
committee hearings we will want the
filing of information to be by the
topics comprising the various complaints
against family court for example if we
in the next several weeks get 12
specific
um
bits of testimony about violation of the
Rules of Evidence all of those will go
in that Rules of Evidence complaint file
testimony from the various stakeholder
groups and from individuals
from the public will be collated
for that reason in order for one's
testimony to be helpful
as the special committee eventually
draws conclusions on the way to making
recommendations to the Judiciary and as
we consider possible new laws testimony
must be specific
specific first in terms of signing the
pink card so you may testify you have
every right to give just your name
however if when we consider your
testimony we have some questions for you
some follow-ups when a couple of weeks a
couple of months from now we look at
your testimony and we want some
clarification you will do your case well
if you put on the pink card your contact
information phone and email once again
you do not have to do it but if you've
come to testify because you want to
convince us of something that will help
as we follow up
second
in terms of specifics is the testimony
that we will allow
generalized statements are not helpful
oh everybody knows the courts are bias
against
dads in a custody hearing
I don't know that and that's not helpful
that's a broad assertion it is not fact
to say the judge didn't follow the rules
of evidence proves nothing
however
if in your testimony
you tell us specifics on what day was
the trial held at what time before what
judge in what courtroom and at what
point was evidence proffered that was
refused now we have something to go on
we may go back and try to look at the
trial record to get a context
anything short of specifics like that
will not help your case and will waste
everyone's time
so prove your case
and if others do the same on a
particular issue or another issue we may
have something to go on in terms of
reform
next
please understand those of you who would
come to testify we will not retry your
case so do not come and give us a story
about how your case was mangled in the
court
now in colonial days the legislature
often received petitions for the redress
of grievances
according to former house legal counsel
The Honorable Charles G Douglas III this
was because and I quote a memo to me
there were few standing committees in
the legislature there were few
bureaucratic agencies in the executive
branch to deal directly with the
Grievances of individuals or groups of
citizens
so much of the legislation that was
introduced was enacted in response to
petitions in other words the the court
the legislature was pretty much the
court the executive department it was
almost all three branches of government
minus a royal king
that
retrying of cases however
stopped
in the September term of 1818
the Supreme Court of New Hampshire in
the case of Meryl V Sherborne wrote this
an act of the legislature awarding a new
trial and an action which has been
decided in a court of law as an exercise
of judicial power
it is also in its operation
retrospective for these two reasons
it is unconstitutional
at the end of the opinion merovi
Sherborne and I believe members of this
committee have been provided with a copy
and of
councilor Douglas's statement the
legislature cannot pass an act and our
judgment therefore is that the
proceedings of this case which was the
request to retry a case is quashed
so therefore any testimony that appears
to ask the special committee to
challenge a Court verdict
will be interrupted and not allowed to
continue
in terms of witnesses stakeholder groups
because they represent many individuals
will be given some considerable time in
making their presentation but they too
may not make broad generalizations but
rather must cite specific instances with
dates approximate time in the hearing
the name of the judge presiding and the
perceived error that was made again
prove your case members of the public
will be given five minutes and this will
be timed
house rule 100 allows this to happen
we hope that there will be a four minute
30 second polite warning no noise
to let you know you got 30 seconds to
wrap up with a less polite noise at five
minutes when you're done
you'll be allowed to finish your
statement and then your microphone will
be turned off now we do this for a
couple of reasons number one
they're probably as we get going will be
numbers of people who wish to testify
and if we just let individuals testify
until they run out of air
um we may be going on forever
secondly to make an allegation of a
perceived error doesn't take that long
it does not take that long to tell us
the date the place the time where in the
trial who is the judge and the
perception of error or if there was no
error
that the rule that was followed should
be changed that won't take long so this
will help people be on point
those of you who wish to testify please
fill out a pink card
hand it to the nearest member of the
committee don't walk it up to me but
committee who will then pass it along
now
if you filled out a pink card and it's
come in
and you've heard the testimonies and
realize what you've written out won't be
accepted
you can have another bite of the Apple
if I call your name just say Mr chairman
I would like to revise my testimony may
I testify it another time the answer is
yes you may because we want your input
to be as helpful to your case as it can
be
if you have written testimony to hand in
please make sure it is that kind of
testimony we I for one will not read
through volumes of stuff that talk about
this one is corrupt and that judge's
cousin is such I I don't read those
things
um so don't don't waste my paper please
or yours boil it down to what we need to
hear
there are 10 of us and there's a Clerk's
filed so if you wish to turn in things
11 copies would be helpful
and because we have much to do we will
adjourn at 12 noon
if somebody is testifying at 12 noon
that person will be allowed to continue
but will be the last person to testify
for that day believe me some of us
around the table have been here to nine
o'clock at night because there was only
one day set aside for a Committee
hearing any pink cards that are left
over at noon that have not been utilized
I haven't called on you will go to the
head of the list for subsequent weeks
um we are presently scheduled for May
2nd 9 16 and 23 at 9 30 in the morning
we will take off May 30th which is the
day after Memorial Day
I have asked the committee to reserve in
their calendar the first three Tuesdays
of June we may or may not need them
we'll find out
so if you did not get called upon to
testify and the new now it comes
I will start with you and others from
that leftover batch the next week unless
you can't be here and then give me a
date and I'll put your name and date in
that
before we break for the summer the
committee may decide to make some
preliminary suggestions to the Judiciary
this will be discussed and we may make
those suggestions we may not
we will call upon the Judiciary later on
this spring to make comments for example
let's suppose we are going to be opening
up that file on Rules of Evidence
we would like the Judiciary then to come
and give us specifically printed copy
and testimony what those Rules of
Evidence are
it's been
I have discovered that there are numbers
of people who know about Rules of
Evidence because they've watched 22
years of Law and Order on TV to which I
will say despite my great respect for
councilor Jack McCoy those are criminal
cases we're talking about civil the
rules are different so we will hear from
the Judiciary not so much as a rebuttal
at this point but to outline the
specifics of those issues that seem to
be presented to us
I believe when our work is finished a
few of us will draft a final report
which will be reviewed by the entire
special committee for revision and we
hope eventually final approval
individual members may decide to craft
some draft legislation for the next year
I conclude with reading the notice and
disclaimer this was printed
on the back page of the last
House calendar
and I have been asked to read this
statement at this and every committee
meeting because it I we want to make
very sure that if you're coming here
you will speak in ways that we will hear
so here goes
the special committee on the Family
Division of the Circuit Court was formed
to investigate allegations of
irregularities including failure to
follow or enforce statutes
unwarranted waiver of or failure to
follow court rules delay in rendering
decisions denial of due process and
other procedural issues
the committee will conduct hearings
relative to the process of the Family
Division of the circuit court and may
make recommendations for future
legislation
the purpose of the committee is to
discover areas where changes in
procedures or changes in law regarding
the Family Division of the Circuit Court
may be made
the purpose of this special committee is
not to retry the cases of citizens who
disagree with the outcome of litigation
members of the public will be given an
opportunity to testify and present
information to the committee
because of the number of people who may
wish to testify there may be a time
limit imposed on each person testifying
which is permissible under house rule
100. appropriate subject matter for
testifying will be limited to specific
instances of where there seemed to be
irregularities in process procedure or
adherence to rules and statutes those
testifying about subject matter related
to a court case or who submit
documentation relating to a court case
should know that both will be made part
of the public record
therefore subject matter that is either
confidential or may be under seal should
not be discussed or submitted to the
committee as disclosure of such matters
would be a violation of Statute or a
court order and let me parenthetically
add this will be the burden of this will
be on those who testify it may not be
immediately apparent to any of us in the
committee or to me as the chairman
uh something that is said shouldn't have
been said I may not know that so you're
going to have to be very careful about
this
finally the committee reserves the right
to not accept written or oral testimony
or materials which would in its judgment
violate the foregoing
so with that is the long introductory
statement anybody wished to respond from
the committee and I call upon my vice
chair
thank you Mr chair I was honored when
um the speaker asked if I would agree to
serve as the vice chair of this
committee I am honored because the
speaker asked me I am honored to be able
to serve with the distinguished chair of
Children and Family
I have uh
my normal home is with the Judiciary
Committee and I have had a long
experience with the Judiciary Committee
and uh I'm ranking member uh
foreign
I follow closely the decisions that are
made by my fellow legislators who serve
on other committees when those decisions
seem to
um involve the workings of the judicial
branch since in fact it's the Judiciary
Committee charged with oversight of the
judicial branch
it was of great concern to me
when I discovered
now I guess it's at least a month ago
perhaps more that a Bill had passed
children and family law
overwhelmingly supported by the members
of children and family law that
expressed concern about the operation of
the Family Division of the circuit court
and express that concern so strongly
that among other things they ask that
the committee children and family law be
given subpoena power to subpoena the
judges of this state
I must say that that shocked me
and it was that shock that caused me to
go to speak with
um
uh with speaker Packard
about my concern and I believe that I
was not alone and I know that the chair
sitting on my left
was immediately involved and receptive
to concern expressed about that bill and
for that I I thank him
um
I have uh listened for the first time to
what the chair has just said and was
interested in much of what he said
and concerned because it did sound to me
as if it were
trial rather than a legislative hearing
in which the legislative Hearing in
which we would be collecting information
as much as we could from disparate
sources to make sure that we in the
legislature do our part
um in in how the three branches of
government work but recognizing that
there are three branches and for example
recognizing that it is not the
legislature but the Judiciary that makes
the rules for the operation of the
judicial branch if we were to
um
uh
to move to change those rules
um I think we would quickly find
ourselves before the courts which seems
a little uh something that's full of
irony
um
I look forward to working with this
committee with members from both the
Children and Family Services the
children and family law committee that
has one perspective and one line of
experience and members of the Judiciary
Committee that have another set of
experiences and knowledge because I
think together
we could create a very rich and deep
understanding of the complexities that
we face in society today and that are
reflected in the incredible challenges
uh faced by the Family Division
we might find that the Family Division
is suffering because of lack of
resources and that is something that
falls specifically within the venue of
the legislative branch in terms of
creating positions and in terms of of
financing and that's a perfectly
appropriate thing for us to do I also
think that we can serve and very
important function in giving people an
opportunity
to articulate their concerns and know
that somebody is listening to those
concerns as long as they are presented
in a way that the chair so
thoroughly uh discussed not to retry a
case but to see where there might be
what could be called a pattern or
practice
that gets in the way of the family court
doing what we would hope the family
pre-judging I come here with the same
feelings that any one of us might have
as Citizens about yeah I like that
decision or no I don't like that
decision but without believing that
there are institutional
um
factors about those those decisions and
I I know that I I am convinced that at
the end of this practice under the
leadership of the chair
this committee will calmly
intelligently thoughtfully and in a very
balanced way
identify ways that we in the legislature
can do a better job legislating and
therefore hoping that that will help the
Judiciary
doing a better job adjudicating so I
thank you for listening and I am looking
forward to hearing what others say
thank you madam Vice chair in terms of
the bill that passed I believe
unanimously it was house resolution 14
and
um it looked good in a lot of ways but
we were informed that a couple of items
of it
were in violation of either house rules
or something else and at that point and
I I believe
Madam Vice chair you you were very much
conversing with the speaker as well I
said that the request of a committee
that house resolution 14 spoke of is
something I'd like to go forward and so
collectively that's why we're here is
the real gist the real meat of house
resolution 14
um here we are anyone else on the
committee yes the chair counselor
so I appreciated your comments I'm
honored to be appointed to this
committee I did want to just point out
since
and we can talk about this later but I
think in your opening remarks you said
that anyway I am a practicing attorney
in the Family Division and I am a
certified Guardian Ad Litem in the
Family Division it's only about 20 maybe
30 now of my practice but just based on
the comments that you had made I I had
been vetted with my leadership and you
and I had talked and I didn't see that
being a practicing member would
disqualify me but if it does perhaps we
can talk about that you passed my wadia
counselor okay
okay thank you
yes uh con this may embarrass you but
then again you are a lawyer so maybe it
won't but uh I did ask you some push
questions to try to see if in my opinion
you could be a disinterested party and
you pass with flying colors
thank you very much welcome do my best
anyone else says we
begin
wow
I am expecting a tsunami of pink cards
starting next week I have no pink cards
here nobody has come indicating you wish
to testify I hope I didn't scare you off
but I do hope okay would you fill out a
and remember the kind of testimony that
meanwhile counselor you may be
interested I'm reading several
equivalents of
introductory to law for idiots I'm
really plugging through it I've watched
22 years of Law and Order knowing the
differences and I'm really trying to get
up to speed on this and no I'm not going
to law school but I did pass a practice
LSAT exam
maybe you could pass those books on to
me and I could see if I could learn a
the chair recognizes Paula
or worma were me and um I'll start my
watch you got five minutes and just
remember the parameters in which you may
testify okay yes sir
um I witnessed a terrible Injustice in
the family court
in a case where the court didn't even
have subject matter jurisdiction
uh three separate judges basically
stripped a protective parent of custody
and then they proceeded to scare her
straight out of the state
and handed custody to the abusive ex
then they basically or ransacked her
half of the marital State and gave it to
the husband
as a result of this terrible Injustice I
decided I was going to do an audit on
the courts
I basically sold my home built out a van
to live in and drove up here last fall
and I'm here again still auditing the
courts
I wish to be recognized as an expert
to testify for the length of time is Mr
head I know what's going on I know the
reasons
have already raised an issue of three
judges stripping a parent of custody you
have not provided name date time place
specifics it is not it is not
you got to hit it again I'm sorry I will
bring the information this is the
organizational meeting yes it is I'm
just telling you that I understand
statutory reasons for what is going on
is wrong I understand constitutional
reasons I understand the reasons the
judges are violating the rules I
understand that in general and I've
looked at probably 150 to 200 of these
cases they don't issue scheduling orders
and that's why some of these cases are
carrying on for 15 years they never
schedule something for trial I can bring
you specific instances when it's time to
bring in testimony when it's time to
bring in testimony uh yes please do the
rules I've articulated will be in place
okay but my point here today is I need
more than five minutes I would like as
much time as you give to the judicial
branch I will give you five minutes and
I may call upon you to come back again
but I will not give you a recognition as
an expert witness or blank blanket
amount of time you will have to prove
yourself if you prove yourself in the
first presentation you make you may be
called upon again
seeing no further pink cards I would
like to introduce to us
um
I heard some bad news the other day that
attorney head who had been the
consultant I believe to both of our
committees
um at least I meet him over there by the
law books a lot is moving on to another
position and and would you come on up
please and introduce yourself and tell
us tell us a few things about yourself
so before the year 2000.
they weren't microphones
we could hear them too my name is Lori
Platt and I've worked for could you
spell that please Lori
l-o-r-r-i-e Platt p-l-a-t-t Lori Platt
thank you
um I I did work for the house up until
the year 2000 at which time I left to
work at the Supreme Court where I've
remained ever since
um and I've been asked to provide
whatever information and research I can
for this committee and um
I don't know what else to tell you I I
do have some background in the Family
Division in that I
my youngest child came to our family
when he was eight so I've been through
the
in order to adopt him he was in the
foster care system so I have some
experience with that
um
I don't know what else to tell you
before I was with the house I was with
the attorney general's office
what position do you hold with the
Supreme Court I'm the reporter of
decisions and would you explain I know
what that is because you you taught me
what that is but would you explain in
case anyone else doesn't know I think my
prelim my sort of primary responsibility
there is to oversee the issuance of
opinions and orders but I I do do a lot
of research for the court and Drafting
and I I
at the current time I am the secretary
for the administer the advisory
committee on rules but I will be
I will be giving that position to Tim
goodis our clerk our the clerk of the
court so that I can better serve this
committee will you be replacing attorney
head as the liaison to our committees
not this committee but the ones we come
from I don't I don't know how that's
going to work I've only been asked to
staff this particular committee
um okay I take my guidance from Diane
Martin and the Chief Justice if we're
nice to you
maybe you'll do it
I current I up until very recently I was
working many more than 40 hours a week
so I have been trying to with their
support curtail my work but to the
extent that I can help anybody I that
really is something I'd like to do
for going forward and you can certainly
if you haven't already begin the
research
it's the several specific charges that
are made against Family Court
um
the judges all seem to lean over
backwards to favor the ones who are pro
se
or the judges don't like people who are
pro se well those those are obviously
two different charges or
um Rules of Evidence aren't being
followed or scheduling protocols aren't
being where there is an allegation that
seems to be coming from several people
um
what are the rules
what other protocols why is the delay is
it fair or unfair that something is put
out
three years
um someone who has complained to us
saying why every time I go to court the
opposite one brings in five more
petitions why does the judge hear that
and not just say enough we're done those
kinds of questions about procedures
um I I know for example what was what my
vice chair articulated the reason
sometimes things are taking time is
there's not enough judges and I think we
got seven more coming to Circuit Court
if this budget keeps that in and is
signed into law so there are answers to
some of the questions uh those would be
good topics to start the research on and
as you listen to testimony here
you'll start to hear Trends too and
certainly you can talk with the the
clerks of the committee and they can say
oh we've got six things in the folder
Mark such and such that would be good to
start formulating
um some answers
okay
for what it's worth as I understand that
the judicial branch at some point will
come over and the judges would I think
some of them would come and answer some
of your questions also
I I don't know when you want to do that
as I've as I'm working on scheduling of
stakeholder groups we've got different
stakeholder groups which are enumerated
in the
um the memo establishing this committee
and I've asked my uh committee
researcher who is doing the scheduling
to not bring the uh Judiciary over early
in the process we want to hear from as
many people as can do it I see rightly
their information their their complaints
only then can the Judiciary come and
explain
um I am heartened and this does not
Prejudice My ultimate decision but I am
heartened already to hear both from
administrative judge king and from the
chief justice that any helpful
anybody else
you have a judge in the family you don't
okay we have okay good well thank you
representative long
thank you thank you Mr chairman
um yeah serving on children and family
for eight years nine years
um there's been allegations of
inconsistency so uh helping to know how
they how the judicial checks themselves
uh may be helpful I know that sticks out
in my mind that
I mean we're here and I you know judge X
decided this way
my friends the same case as mine and
judge W decided this way what wise I
don't think they like me you know so so
uh and the same with uh judicial review
um inconsistencies with that also so
just
a heads up on what uh the chairman also
it would be helpful at
some point
for you or someone from Judiciary to
explain to us to the degree
it should be
in other words no betrayals of
confidence obviously
how your
um and I keep blanking out the name it's
the the group the committee that
investigates the possibility that a
judge has gone bad the judicial combat
committee that's the room to know how
that works okay I mean if you can wing
it now fine if not come back
I'd prefer not to wait because obviously
um
there's private information
and should be private and having been
privy in my day work line of work to
serving as a judge on one of those
things
I I do know the process of how it works
and the confidentialities that are
important but it would perhaps be
um a relief to some members of the
public to know that there is such a
thing
and how it works and what you look for
that would be very helpful I think for
some folks
um
representative Greg
thank you Mr chairman you made me think
of a question
um and actually then you started to ask
a similar thing so on one thing that
we've heard uh multiple times that I
don't really think I need more evidence
of but is people saying that recordings
are being stopped and I know that in
other states on these kind of oversight
committees and stuff they have people
that will go sit in random like
courtrooms and stuff that are actually
from the judicial branch to see if the
recordings are being stopped kind of
like a guest teacher or something is
there any kind of observation that we
have in the judicial system that looks
for stuff like that because there have
been specific incidents as we've seen of
that kind of stuff either they think
it's on record and supposedly the judge
stopped the recording or and then we've
heard that they can't stop that so I'm
really interested to hear more about
kind of how that goes and if there's any
observation or protocol for kind of
regulating that kind of stuff
thank you for underscoring that anyone
who is watching the video of this who
believes this took place because we did
hear some a few examples of that in
children family law committee we would
like to know what day what court what
time so that we can review the tape or
at least ask a court administrative
officer what happened
um
also
at some point
we would like to schedule a road trip to
sit in on Family Court
uh it's probably going to be very
difficult for us to all keep our mouth
shut but we'll try
and speak with someone afterwards
obviously not to review the case we just
heard but from that in other cases we
may have witnessed generalized questions
and then this this occurred to me late
at night when I was reading one of my
intro to law books
what about moot court or mock Court
depending on which term you like where I
mean we do this in the legislature for
new legislators on how to not behave in
the legislature when we're having a
session and you know we'll have somebody
cross in front of the speaker and you
know all of those things you're not
supposed to do to show us what we're not
supposed to do not just by giving you a
list of rules but actually having a play
and so something like moot court or mock
court that could bring out a typical
family court case
with actors
derived from a conflation of numbers of
cases so we're not retrying an exact
case but a generalized one with
subtitles running commentary uh that
would be worth the price of the
admission I think if some point uh you
could get some law students to do that
for us
oh
I'm I'm going to pursue that that's an
interesting idea we have interns at the
Supreme Court uh-huh
uh and the chair now recognizes uh
anybody from the committee who wishes to
ask further questions of
um
you're an attorney I'm going to believe
right yes okay councilor Platt thank you
for coming
seeing none
chair recognizes representative Rudy
I'm sorry I've totally blanked your name
Bernardi I knew that
thank you representative JD Bernardi
Rockingham 36.
um so I was the sponsor of HR 14.
um I am not an aggrieved party in any
family law uh
condition
um I became aware of issues in the
family court system by campaigning when
I campaign I knock on doors I ask
questions about the uh my constituents
or potential constituents what is
bothering you about issues in New
Hampshire whether it be taxation or
whatever uh Second Amendment or and it's
issues that they raise they raised
with a reasonable frequency problems in
the Family Law Court you know that that
were unique to them so I became a
sponsor of the legislation
to essentially see if we can get to the
legitimate number of due process issues
and I say legitimate in that I just
didn't take this on because I heard
complaints
I actually met with these folks in
meetings and we reviewed physical
documents of here's the judge's decision
here's the cases here's the problems
that where where there were uh
seeming divergences from some sort of
semblance of what I considered
reasonable Behavior
my opinion
but that was the Genesis and the
rationale for bringing forward H.R 14.
um
the need for subpoena power well you can
argue one way or another I thought it
was necessary in order to get
um some answers when answers were not
forthcoming
but if the Judiciary is going to be
responsive then we'll get those answers
the issue that I have today is this is
the first time there's been an
opportunity for what I would call a
charter or how this committee is going
to operate and its expectations we're
just hearing it for the first time
um
the people that need to testify that
have the specific experiences that
you're asking for
don't know this yet so there needs to be
some way to publish and get that
information out to them that you are
looking for X Y and Z and and please
come to this committee and make that
case now I don't I don't know if that is
publishable in the calendar or uh you
know some other place but
um
the testimony child and family law heard
on on various bills there was a targeted
bill that would dealt with uh
um
issue a b or c and people came and
testified on that this seems to be all
right the door is thrown open to
potentially anything but what things and
what what do you want so you uh chairman
Pearson went over a selected list of
criteria
um
I I do I do think that needs to be fully
published and made available so people
know and the dates that you're having
hearings so they can potentially plan
take time off from work or whatever
activities they may have and and show up
and and actually present the information
that they need to present so you can
interrogate the uh issue further I have
a press release ready to go just waiting
for this specific day it's committee
meeting to end I just wanted to hear a
little bit more from my colleagues I was
intending to speak more specifically
with some of them over the weekend but
it was the weekend from hell but the
press release is ready to go which will
do exactly that say when where give the
rules to the road and I do hope the
newspapers publish it
um
as I send it out because it is designed
to do exactly what you suggest secondly
I will ask my committee researcher and
it may be either you or my committee
assistant to go back to those retained
bills and children and family law and
find the pink cards and see those pink
cards who came to testify as a aggrieved
individual if this contact information
so that they can be contacted and
informed this thing is rolling and then
thirdly representative you really did
your homework and those people who you
sat down with who produce documents uh
call them let them know
we are scheduled to meet the first four
Tuesdays of May 2 9 16 23 maybe the
first three Tuesday Mornings of June but
that way they'll know ahead of time
so one additional question then could
you potentially publish your
um
editorial or whatever in the calendar as
listed you know normally we list a bill
and what were subject matters being
discussed if that could also be in the
calendar with with the specificity that
you went over the kind of information
you're looking for so people who follow
the legislature can look there and
identify yes there's
this is how it's going to work
I will speak to the clerk of the house
we what a notice is I've already
submitted the dates for May and if I
misspoke it was it's not the first
second and third of June it's the first
second and third Tuesdays of June so
it's a whole bunch of Tuesdays but not
the 30th of May I will speak to the
clerk if you would speak to your
constituents we'll try to find the ones
who testified if there are similar
bills about the Judiciary that came to
the Judiciary Committee maybe you can
ask for the pink cards to be researched
and
press release we'll go out this
afternoon if you can think of any other
way to get the word out there let me
know
just in the calendar that's it thank you
okay and thank you and it was only on
two very minor points but were deemed to
be disqualifiers that the H.R 14
resolution was
um tabled everything else as you know
sailed out of here
we didn't know until later there were a
couple of disqualifiers so here we are
here's the committee H.R 14 I hope
wanted
is this on good morning Mr chair
uh forgive me I wasn't prepared to speak
today if you're not in Conformity with
the house rules I'll give you your pink
card back
but uh I just wanted to address what I
heard from Miss Platt okay I think a
little Clarity on who is doing what over
at the judicial branch right now might
be very helpful
I wrote an email to Mr head yesterday
concerning whether an audio recording
was supposed to be 10 or 20 minutes I
could give you date time docket number
I sort of planned on discussing that
offline with him
uh but just a little more clarity on
what's going on and who we can bring
these issues to at this time would be
helpful if you'd like the tame Diamond
docket number that I can give it to you
otherwise that's all I have to say when
it's time to make your presentation
after you've done any Consulting and I
do appreciate your doing that we get a
lot of people coming through here who
have not done their homework thank you
for trying to do yours yeah it's an
issue of who do I do it with the
judicial branch thank you
okay
um I don't know the house rules over
there but um perhaps Council can let him
know if this is admissible and if so who
he speaks with so maybe you could have a
little you know next party afterwards
perfect
thank you and the chair recognizes
Joseph J is it Nugent
okay I think it was the last time I read
then it wasn't you have similar
handwriting
thank you my name is Joseph Nugent I
live in Effingham I wanted to just start
this is the first time I've ever
testified here in Concord okay but I am
very grateful for the process of this
special committee uh beginning I know
that today is just an introductory day
I did have a question whether or not
people might be able to testify more
than one time before the committee in
their five minutes because unfortunately
I have a family case that's become very
complex and I'm not sure that the issues
could fairly be addressed in only one
five-minute presentation but well why
don't we try you for one and if you do
conform to the the ways of we're
receiving testimony
um what we'll do is hear from others and
then we'll
if you did a good job the first time
we'll give you a second maybe a third
bite of the Apple
good and I'm hoping that that doesn't
become necessary unfortunately I think
that some of the issues might be so
preliminarily today I didn't want to
miss an opportunity to have the
microphone where we had time before noon
I did have concerns about due process
and irregularities in my family case
and I just believe that in general this
is an important check and balance from
what I found from enduring the family
court here in New Hampshire
that without a check and balance that's
instrumental in our government
problems occur and specifically in my
case I'm very concerned about an RSA
regarding
access to 9-1-1 calls
so there's a rule in New Hampshire
that's affected my family case and my
relationship with my nine my now almost
11 year old child where the situation
where my son had been taken from me was
recorded
by e911
however the legislature here has passed
a rule that doesn't allow for the
issuance of that 9-1-1 call
without a judge's signature
now I've made this this request in many
motions before the family court and
before our Supreme Court during my
appeal process even our Supreme Court
has denied me the the 9-1-1 call now
I've had evidence which when I have more
chance to prepare I will provide
evidence to this committee that shows
that the situation was a 10-minute phone
call this is done on a time and dated
stamped uh piece of computer paper
ticker that comes out at the County
office where the 9-1-1 calls go through
and during the resulting criminal
process of my case where I was charged
with domestic violence I was charged
with even hitting my son which was
thrown out of court
this 9-1-1 call is evidence but I was
only provided during the criminal
Discovery process for six minutes and
seven seconds of this call
it was altered because it was not
provided to me so the issue that I'd
like to bring before the legislature is
to show that there's a flaw in the law
in my opinion that comes out of this
legislature that allows our state and
our government to withhold evidence from
the public from a person who's a part of
the call so as the committee looks at
rules to perhaps re-evaluate or
additional legislation to provide in the
future I didn't want to miss the
opportunity to bring out that very
important case because this occurred
when my son was four and a half years
old he's going to turn 11 in in May when
you come back it would be helpful to us
if you have the RSA number in your hand
for us it would be helpful if we know
the specific dates and time roughly time
of the call and which judges turn down
your request it would be helpful in was
there a criminal case or only a civil
yes
you want to show that I was found not
guilty by a jury of my peers who threw
out all the charges against me and I
still have not been able to have
unsupervised visitation with my child
was there um was there in the discovery
phase of your criminal trial
um
are you saying it during Discovery all
they got was six minutes and change the
tape uh even with your attorney asking
for more yes this one right before I'm
going to stop now because it's starting
to move into retrying your case and
which is a valid thing to do but not for
this committee's purposes so when you
come back if you would have chapter and
verse as much as you could how many
times
um
a judge was asked to release more of the
9-1-1 call when who where and so on
that's the kind of specifics we need as
we start to look at what changes need to
be made so I'll let you go now but you
made a great start and
um I will sure
um yes the vice chair please
thank you uh very much the point that
you raised is a is an interesting point
because it does show the difference
between the legislative branch and the
judicial branch in uh the Judiciary
Committee which actually meets in the
same room so I feel at home here we have
had a number of bills relating to what
can and cannot be released by 9-1-1 I'm
not sure that children and family law
has had any of those so this is some an
issue that we're familiar with but if I
could just ask
um it's is it not true that you're
talking about more than one case one
that would have been in in criminal
court and then one that would have been
in family court is that true
correct and in my particular instance
representative there the case was
divided because the DV charges against
Me In The Family Court civilly have
their own docket number they had their
own hearing the family court had a
different docket number
different proceedings there were
criminal charges made against me some
went in the district court and also
before the superior court with appeals
that went in both from the family part
of my case before The Supreme Court as
well as the DV part of the case and this
is an instrumental piece of evidence
that I'm still looking for now six years
later I realize how if I could sure
please I realized how how painful this
is for you and how complex it is but I
would just remind you that this
committee is looking exclusively at the
Family Division of the Circuit Court
nothing
here
we have no Authority and no reason to be
looking at any actions in other courts
including of course the criminal courts
and uh District in yes I understand that
so I just want to remind you of that for
when you will look forward to hearing
from you when you come back yes thank
you for that because when this is
ultimately provided for me my
understanding of the Rules of Evidence
is that this will be information not
available to me at the time of my
hearings and will be instrumental in
asking for a new trial so that's why
this is so important for me to somehow
get attention to this matter to provide
this important evidence so that I can
try to resurrect a relationship with my
son thank you Mr Newton any anyone else
in the committee
just curious
um was the evidence that was admitted in
the criminal case was that allowed to
come into your Civil Trial
it was not allowed to come in to the
Civil Trial
and that's part of the due process area
that this committee is trying to take a
look at where there were due process
violations and in my opinion these
happen because there is no check and
balance and my concern is for many other
parents who faced this I did it really
okay I'm going to cut you off that that
was a specific question I wanted to know
that if evidence was admissible in the
criminal case
to what degree was that not allowed into
your civil case and don't answer the
question now but answer it when you come
back please okay thank you
and thank you for your testimony
well I don't see anything else before us
unless anybody on the committee has
something you'd like to weigh in on good
all right this uh concludes our
organizational day and we will meet
again 9 30 next Tuesday
and that's you know who's going to be
invited
um could I ask the committee researcher
who whom do we have scheduled in terms
I'm sorry
dcyf
can we expect uh are we going to noon or
could we be going to two or we're going
to noon okay we're going to be going to
noon okay thank you
yeah yeah so we can plan you know yeah
well yeah
thank you all uh yes
could you come up to an old man's ears
please
foreign